Naseer asks sometimes my passion is seen
as aggression how do I walk the line do
I change to someone more passive this
year this year
first of all don't change for anybody
now finding that balance of grace and
having that tack to be consumable is a
process I somewhere around eighth grade
into sophomore year didn't hit the right
tone anymore I was too intense through
my classmates and I literally I could
taste it cuz I have empathy and kind of
self-awareness and it's an ongoing
process like you know for example my tea
notes are interesting I just referenced
them I'm actually evolving that cadence
throughout the conversation of the tone
because I'm reacting to the body
language of everybody else it's not
about how do you become more passive
because I'd hate that suck the passion
out of you which is a huge variable to
success controlling it and people saying
you're just a little too much I have a
feeling that that's predicated on you
caring too much for it to be valuable
for you I'm gonna say that again for
everybody the only reason I think that
I'm able to pull off this is because
there's a healthy balance of caring
about you when you care more about your
audience than what you have to say you
start winning right when you when you
care more about your global audience
listening or watching and it's not about
the 15 minutes and what am I gonna get
out of it and sure in a right hook world
it's always there let me let me actually
use this question to define something
that I don't think I talked about in the
book I live in the world of Jab Jab Jab
right hook let me tell you two
interesting things about I don't
necessarily feel that I ever have to
throw a right hook and I don't expect
the need to throw a right hook based on
my jabs in micro levels at the holistic
level I do also there's another part
that we never talked about is there
which is what happens when the right
hook doesn't land
I'm actually not disappointed what
happens when I do all awesome stuff for
these guys or anybody else I don't have
any expectation that they're gonna do
something awesome for me and Rick
eliminating that lack of expectation
opens up a world of where you can
provide so based on your question based
on my intuition might vibe on this
question it has a whole lot to do with
you caring more about than the people
that are judging you that are telling
you to chill out they're telling you
that because not about your passion
because take it from me and many other
people people love passion they don't
like selfish passion wait subscribe I
need subscriptions because I can't push
this many right hooks in social so
subscribe